people think this stuff is crazy right
like like
and trust me i wrote this morning about
how central bank digital currencies are
going to be one of the greatest
violations of human rights and history
people are like what are you talking
about well did you read the piece right
um
but i want to walk through a couple of
things that uh are direct examples this
isn't you and i uh pontificating about
this this isn't like us all putting our
tin foil hats on and like oh it wouldn't
be crazy if they did this is real life
examples so first let's start with uh
the central bank digital currencies
we've got the bank of england who's
explicitly stated uh and and majid
brought up uh kind of this article that
said hey look they want to basically say
here's what you can spend money on
here's what you can we know china's
already pursuing this we now see that
canada quite literally is saying if you
donate money to this cause right we're
going to come after you uh business
owners who are literally just serving
coffee to the truckers right we've seen
that video that's gone viral and so this
is not uh
like a crazy idea like this is happening
in real time
the other thing is around this idea of
like what you can eat because i think
when people see they're like oh they'll
never get to that point
i saw the video of the new york city
mayor saying that he's gonna get
everyone on like his vegan diet yeah
it's like wait a minute like who said
vegan diets were the best diet right
like i don't know it just sounds crazy
to me yeah he's trying to institute like
meatless mondays or something
i mean
that's the thing about all them this is
something bitcoiners myself include i've
been covering
for some time is this encroachment it's
like a slow drip towards these systems
and we've seen it over the last two
years
specifically like two weeks to flatten a
curve okay let's just get the old people
vaccinated now actually if you're over
40 let's get everybody but now we need
to vaccinate the kids and it's just like
this
constant moving of the goal post and
the thing about it like i've threads on
twitter you can go check them out like
these people
these people in power i mean augustin
carson's
specifically is the the head of the bank
of international settlements the bis
came out a couple years ago and
described
exactly what they want to do at the
cbdc's they want to be able to control
where you spend your money how quickly
you spend your money what you can spend
it on whether or not you can actually
spend it depending on what you've done
or said in the past and that's part of
i guess the great psyop that's going on
right now is these
these people who
want to usher us into these digital
panopticons will say it publicly there's
video there's receipts and
uh
like you said people think we're crazy
for for calling this out but you can
literally point to it they tell you
exactly what they want to do so
i'm just gonna read for a second here
i just typed in new york city mayor
meatless monday that was my starting
point real real genius over here
and the first thing that comes up is a
politico article that talks about the
mayor eric adams former new york police
department captain traded jelly donuts
for kale smoothies when diagnosed with
type 2 diabetes five years ago since
then he reversed vision loss and nerve
damage he shed 35 pounds and he anointed
himself a spokesperson for a plant-based
lifestyle it was written in december of
2021. okay what surprised me is the next
uh
result
mayor de blasio announces city-wide
meatless mondays so not even mayor out
before he even got there got de blasio
and he said that cutting back on meat a
little will improve new yorkers health
and reduce greenhouse gas emissions
[Laughter]
so okay
so then i went and i looked and uh what
he did back in 2019 was de blasio
introduced meatless mondays across all
new york city public schools and the
idea was uh the 1800 public schools will
no longer serve meat on mondays to their
1.1 million students which started in uh
july of 2019.
and then uh there's an article
um
in the indy 100 that says new york's
first vegan mayor now talking about eric
adams makes history with meat-free
fridays in schools
so we now have
40
of the school week
kids aren't eating meat in school
and this is not
as a parent somebody making the decision
it's not hey i as the student don't want
to eat meat this is the government
telling the kids
what they're going to eat in a
one-size-fits-all dietary uh mandate
which seems pretty crazy well it's
really crazy and again it's compounding
and doubling down on the problem that
got us here in the first place which is
like top town control the food pyramid
like the food pyramid that they released
in the 70s or 80s whenever they did that
it was telling people to eat like 12
servings of bread a day that have like
sugars and like insane amounts of
fruit which in and of itself isn't bad
but like then they demonize meat like
steak and i think it's i eat steak eggs
and bacon it's pretty much my diet
i
have diabetes runs in my family uh and i
don't have it i
have 20 20 visions still i think
when it comes to diets there's another
area we've been talking about the
government trying to top down control
money with cbdc's but now with diet too
they just want they're trying to
granularly control
complex systems the human body being one
of them by saying hey here's the pyramid
of food you need to eat and that is
arguably what's led to the spike in
obesity
and diabetes that we've seen in this
country in the last 40 50 years and
it's like this government does not have
i don't know maybe they do have your
best interests at heart but their their
advice
has never really led to good outcomes